[Musique]
ouais au revoir à demain
Conley saclink Italie colocasia Sione lui
Herrera dis-moi que je travaille beaucoup mais j'essaie
de manger pourquoi les droits et l'exercice aident
ça aide aussi que tu dois aimer ce que
tu fais non Luigi pas Jésus ou Sanjay
pound run Colosseo Rahzel ha ha je serais
prêt pour une classe principale de Leonie ils
me tiennent je charge son bon amour j'adore mon cours du
lundi soir ils sont incroyables et
ils travaillent très dur mais le lecteur est
difficile financièrement est-ce que ça vaut le coup ce n'est
pas ça  ce que nous ne sommes pas payés oh chérie
non super tu ne dis pas de caméras sur le sol
Judas West Indies sont basserman dit
Joseph Kahn secondes et quels papiers je
sens le grésillement maintenant nous pouvons aller à mon travail le
plus important qui est mon travail de mère
où nous  allez voir ma fille
et sa fanfare présenter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le spectaculaire sudirman Todd
[Musique]
vous avez bien sonné hier soir
Merci Mulan man maryfayce sur
Deauville un psychique Thomas que j'aime
bien c'est Fe effets sur le déjeuner
Billy pas CIPA  CLO Kuvira Samir à propos de
tsukushi alors SWA oublie ça c'est triste
qu'elle doive travailler plus d'un travail mais
tant qu'elle aime ça
je sais ouais je veux dire que je suis parfois seule à la maison
et donc quand elle rentre à la maison je
veux dire c'est bien Billy  Sibylla
Parvati desi appelle Yahoo come
D'Amelio day lives America hella ne voyons-nous pas le
mobile est le compte d'examen est l'arsenic
rosetta bye-bye onyx noir pas un caillou
nie la conception de Mille das une
automobile est uc-san Seneca Doane un
Kentucky  regardez Lama Luca no hado ilaha
zona
irma kleber Vav Han lire pour Edie
qui est Paul education no kamijou - x
packs d'enrobage suisses sur Maxwell pas de
capital être là et regarder des
milliers et des milliers et des milliers d'
enseignants et de parents et d'enfants était très
très puissant et il a  ne s'est jamais produit
en Arizona avant que je ne sois très fier, je
veux dire, je pensais que c'était très bien que
tout le monde s'implique vraiment propre
Arizona dit maintenant que je suis
fou consetta basserman boys bonjour
Mohinder
country mil  der rires derrière moi
Ligue jetez un oeil dans votre public
j'ai 90 élèves et j'ai trois
minutes par jour pour un enseignement individuel
avec eux en gros c'est juste assez de
temps pour leur dire bonjour espere Palafox
un mouvement pour Edie
Jennifer Samaras auto-sélection Académie
Mada éducateur améloïde complet
un papa au citoyen Duchamp même
sur l'avenue de l'aide publique à l'éducation de l'Arizona
principal des électrons à terre c'est ce dont les
gens se soucient le plus quand je
frappe aux portes c'était très important
d'impliquer mes filles dans cela
c'est un sacrifice tellement énorme que je  Je suis également
heureux qu'elle soit prête à aider à réparer l'Arizona
pour aider à réparer l'Arizona ce qui est cassé en
Arizona, le gouvernement et nos écoles
et beaucoup de choses que j'aime Cunha de
Mille partent mais nous pratiquons uniquement la résolution
sociale dire la stratégie terminée vous
rencontrez Molly Kyle  Jennifer est une collectionneuse Makaha
physique, cela n'arrive pas, c'est très
courageux de votre part de sortir et de
défendre l'éducation Jennifer ouais faites-
moi un plaidoyer  se disent qu'un Tom joue
individuellement des spots de programme du
gang de filles soniques pour ne pas pouvoir moudre de la ba
chérie je me suis mariée avec un homme qui a un
bon revenu, c'est un bon travail, c'est la
seule façon dont je peux me permettre l'opportunité d'
enseigner  et je ne suis pas unique, l'enseignement
ne devrait pas être un passe-temps, c'est qu'humiliant
dans la façon dont il est humiliant, le public
est très excité par la question, donc aucun
ensemble n'étudie spécialement l'éducation politique,
écoutez les seniors, alors faites fondre, ils l'utilisent comme
profession unique de Saskatoon Domini pala
fam
ouais hauts seulement c'est Tobi alors que
les revenus sont restés à peu près les mêmes,
le nombre d'élèves que nous servons
augmente, ce qui signifie qu'il y a moins d'argent
disponible par élève par enseignant Je
dois y aller
c'est un Tremezzo collant c'est Ocampo Ali
Ali :
él  hace la prima donnas regarde si
tout ce qui nous a préparé est 11 laissez-moi
regretter dans une palette pisanka
seuls les enfants viennent avec tant de traumatismes
dans leur enfance
vous savez que la famille est divisée avec les lois sur l'
immigration et pa  les loyers en prison et les
parents drogués et ne pas avoir vos
besoins de base satisfaits à la maison, donc là où ils sont en
sécurité, nous les nourrissons, nous les aimons, nous les
serrons dans nos bras et répétons avec
Ceylan Feb une laisse si l'apicio n'est pas à grande
vitesse ouais tu peux  fais ça j'aimerais que nous
soyons valorisés comme les enseignants dans d'autres
pays je serais bien d'avoir ça
pourquoi tu ne penses pas que c'est une bonne
question
échangez un
sermon un pélican et nous serons ici jusqu'à
21h30 environ ce soir, donc encore quatre
heures et demie encore quatre heures et demie
voir Joe la nación fournisseur Cesar a enseigné à
LaMotta Advaita vous connaissez la ville en voyage
le Kaiser haut
mais  dépêchez-vous ouais fatigué oui tournez ça a été
une très longue journée
Lisa j'ai ces Amador gang est av Otomo
je quitterais l'enseignement si je pouvais
profiter un peu plus de la vie et je dois
travailler si dur
Audrey voir cephalus Weaver a dit cos Lisa
clink Fred  à Politico a un sauna s  pa
mouvement de couleur rouge pour Edie
so vivos elección graminées sur Sonam
Kapoor Aurelia Matt donc elle est une suite d'une
conversation commune Lamia varech Juan
Lozano un Arizona donc jusqu'à malposition
comparer les pommes de terre aller visiter un
puits original reportage Gangamma yen country mil
de la américain énergies trochantériennes
Hasan do  moulin ok Becker pas de chanteur aux
Samoans Hassan st.  lait dalla Pagani donc
Académie sur nationale dire Suez on dit
plus doux dimanche Zetas II ne
yo Canada dit Katmandou moulin soi-disant
jours dekap RC a porta moi pour comparer un
zombie vato Spassky phobie donc souvenir
Cosette ingénieur nausée quand la
police de Frankie Laura est désolée de  dit monsieur
whisky Oh Canada
Service du dimanche batterie publique à Napa en
esquivant
l'évasion effective de papa nécessairement
Ézéchias Buchanan est une
parka de professeurs de Chiquita est Delilah non à la Lisa
Klein elle dira emilio de Sena panique
Abaddon la profe SEO sitter à la décision
de s'opposer à lv call canada dong  kyun kar
Finnegan madonna Isetta jeannie
solicitado prison adoptée aloha caper
medical Dumbo elle apparaît comme n'importe quel
sénateur en particulier sur le plan opérationnel, une affaire de personnes
supposée se produire sur toute notre ligue a
AA Giacomin électrochoc jalapeno
courge publique citrouilles Posadas America pendant la
majorité républicaine donc ce bras est
favorable et le plus lourd est  mon Ipod
public politique ne nous mène pas d'un
annonceur donateur électoral P  rieta garde
oh hé pancetta balance fais moi une faveur
carte dynamo sur calicot zeta donneur son
allah allah azza toujours immobilisation
que le résultat je suis un symbole ku tellement désolé